unsicherheitsfaktor astrazeneca was
bedeuten die beschränkungen für den
corona impfplan und das tempo
explodierende infektionszahlen
drangsalierte ärzte in ungarn setzt der
staat auch auf noch nicht für europa
zugelassene impfstoffe aus china und
russland und streit faktor arbeitszeit
das bundesarbeitsgericht sagt wer
zuhause uniformen oder schutzkleidung an
zieht bekommt diese zeit meist nicht
bezahlt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und herzlich
willkommen tsum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann ein schöner von wer kann
und wer sollte sich mit dem impfstoff
von astrazeneca impfen lassen die
ohnehin schon große verunsicherung wird
durch die neuen beschränkungen jetzt
noch verstärkt das räumt selbst die
bundeskanzlerin ein
aktuell gilt folgendes der impfstoff
soll nur noch für menschen über 60
eingesetzt werden
neu ist dass die bundesländer die 60 bis
69 jährigen schon jetzt einen impftermin
mit astrazeneca anbieten dürfen
außerdem können jüngere impfwillige nach
einem aufklärungsgespräch beim hausarzt
weiter mit astrazeneca geimpft werden
neue regeln die das ganze erstmal nicht
beschleunigen christoph distel einpacken
nun zurück in den kühlschrank das war es
erstmal mit astrazeneca für unter 60
jährige auch im impfzentrum burg in
sachsen-anhalt und viele 60 zögern einen
schweren image-schaden für den impfstoff
hat der zuständige koordinator
ausgemacht und in der richtung dass ich
sag mal gut 50 prozent der leute
eigentlich kein astra mehr wohl dass ich
auch biotech bestehen beziehung auch
noch anderen impfstoff lafeld noch gar
nicht da ist
bis juni halten diese dosen noch ob sich
bis dahin genug abnehmer finden muss ich
zeigen auch im impfzentrum köln müssen
sie hinter den kulissen hektisch
umplanen haben astrazeneca sogar für
alle altersgruppen bis nach ostern
gestoppt vorne läuft rund jeder mit
termin wird auch geimpft mit den letzten
bond reserven für die meisten in der
schlange eine eher gute nachricht hätte
ich nein gesagt besonders betroffen von
der sperre sind lehrkräfte und
erzieherinnen astrazeneca ist war ihr
impfstoff spätestens seit die ersten von
ihnen in der imf reihenfolge priorisiert
wurden um wenigstens einen hauch von
präsenzunterricht zu stemmen
der berliner englischlehrerin plocher
etwa hat seine schüler zuletzt vor
weihnachten in echt gesehen jetzt
zwischen erster und zweiter astrazeneca
impfung festzustecken stört ihn
überhaupt nicht die trennung von seiner
siebten klasse aber umso mehr gitarren
unterricht ist für mich für mich keinen
ersatz
und wir kommen nur zurück zum normalen
unterricht wenn wir alle geimpft werden
können zählen auch das impfangebot kann
habe ich sofort angerufen und hatte das
korrekte sechster vor dem nächsten tag
einen termin hatte total genervt sein
seine ungeimpften kollegen sagt er jetzt
warten nun nicht weiter wissen das wolle
niemand und auch der zuständigen
gewerkschaft schwant nichts gutes
also es ist natürlich ein schlag ins
kontor bei dieser infektions lage dort
bedeutet das dass die kitas und die
schulen so nicht öffnen können dann muss
es jetzt dem bei und akuter moderner
sein fordert die gew und zwar für
durchweg alle lehrkräfte damit es trotz
astrazeneca krise bei der bildung
irgendwie weitergehen kann
wer schon eine astrazeneca impfung hat
und sich jetzt fragt wie es mit der
zweite impfung weitergeht in unserer zdf
heute app gibt es antworten auch dazu ob
betroffene zeitdruck besteht die
europäische arzneimittelagentur gab
vorhin bekannt sie sieht erstmal kein
alters spezifisches risiko bei dem
impfstoff von astrazeneca
sie will aber kommende woche noch mal
beraten von der whu heißt es viele
staaten hätten keine probleme gemeldet
die bundesregierung schätzt das risiko
nach einigen thrombose fällen eben
anders sein lassen sagt wieder einmal
steht also astrazeneca in den
schlagzeilen
es waren die universitätskliniken in
nordrhein westfalen die alarm geschlagen
haben
die westfalen hatten wir nach kenntnis
des ministeriums bis jetzt acht schwere
ereignisse die mit astrazeneca impfung
in verbindung gebracht werden und
darunter sind auch
mit ihrer entscheidung folgt die
bundesregierung der empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission den
einhergehenden vertrauensverlust in den
impfstoff muss sie wohl zwangsläufig in
kauf nehmen
offenheit ist glaube ich die beste und
transparenz die beste möglichkeit mit
einer solchen situation umzugehen
andererseits ist es ohne frage ein
rückschlag dass bei einem unserer
verfügbaren impfstoffe in dieser
pandemie für eine bestimmte altersgruppe
offenbar ein erhöhtes risiko besteht
die grünen kritisieren die
verhältnismäßigkeit die gefahr an kurve
zu sterben sei eine impfung deutlich
größer grundsätzlich gilt dass
sicherheit ein hohes gut ist dass
aufklärung ein hohes gut ist aber die
reine individuelle medizinische
beurteilung eines impfstoffs und dessen
sicherheit muss immer in den kontext
anderer risiken gesetzt werden hier ganz
konkret der gefahr an coop 19 schwer zu
erkranken oder zu versterben dass die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema
heute noch einmal mitteilt dass sie kein
alters spezifisches risiko bei
astrazeneca sieht dürfte die
verunsicherung hierzulande noch einmal
vergrößern
große hoffnung liegt auf den hausärzten
die jetzt nach und nach impfen dürfen
und die ja ihre patienten am besten
kennen
aber gerade sie sollen eigentlich auch
astrazeneca nutzen weil dieser impfstoff
nicht so extrem gekühlt werden muss
petra neubauer mit einer reportage aus
bayern wo die hausärzte heute mit dem
impfen begonnen haben
eine von vielen fragen die hausarzt dr
thomasstraße müller an diesem morgen
beantworten muss ängste bedenken gerade
was den impfstoff astra zenica betrifft
man kann nur darauf reagieren indem man
die patienten neben individuell auf
kehrt in dem man auch noch deren
individuelles risiko bezüglich dieses
impfstoffs erklärt dr strass müller
bekommt wie alle gut 1600 teilnehmenden
hausärzte in bayern zunächst pro woche
nur circa zehn impfdosen patienten wie
der 78 jährige joachim otto
wenn es kaum erwarten praktisches wie
den hausarzt
er kennt mich haben hier angerufen und
gesagt ihr seid dran
der ansturm ist enorm viele hatten sich
seit wochen telefonisch vormerken lassen
doch noch gilt eine impf priorisierung
eine feste reihenfolge
je nach alter und vorerkrankung
schwerpunkt in strass müllers praxis
jetzt die über 70-jährigen mit seinem
vater besucht der hausarzt die
83-jährige lieselotte schmidt die kaum
noch laufen kann
in ihrem fall hilft astrazeneca ist es
doch weniger empfindlich als die vakzine
von bayonetta oder moderner wm-arena
impfstoffe sind eigentlich nicht so gut
transportabel das ist nach wie vor sehr
unklar
und jetzt kann man eben mit astra bei
älteren leuten zu hause impfen sogar
sonderschichten fürs impfen können sich
einige hausärzte vorstellen
voraussetzung sie bekommen genug
impfstoff im stoff wird dringend
gebraucht auch deshalb haben kanzlerin
merkel und der französische präsident
makro mit russlands präsident putin über
eine zusammenarbeit bei der produktion
gesprochen
konkret geht es um den russischen
impfstoff sputnik wie es in der eu noch
nicht zugelassen wird aber von der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde ema
geprüft
ungewöhnlicher schritt der
ministerpräsidenten von bayern und baden
württemberg markus söder und winfried
kretschmann haben einen brief an ihre 14
kollegen und kolleginnen geschrieben
darin fordern sie eine strikte anti
corona politik mit einer konsequenten
umsetzung der notbremse in hotspots
zitat die lage sei ernster als viele
glauben
schleswig holsteins ministerpräsident
günther wies den vorstoß zurück und
sprach von effekthascherei jetzt der
blick auf die zahlen innerhalb von 24
stunden meldeten die gesundheitsämter
dem robert-koch-institut 17.000 51 neue
corona infektionen
das sind 1238 mehr als vergangenen
mittwoch 249 menschen starben in
verbindung mit coop 19
die sieben tage incidents sinkt leicht
auf 1
132,3 nach umgang in dem land mit rund
zehn millionen einwohnern liegt die
inzidenz bei über 600 höher als in fast
allen anderen ländern europas in den
letzten 24 stunden starben 302 menschen
so viele wie nie zuvor in der brandung
die krankenhäuser sind überlastet
gleichzeitig wird im eiltempo geimpft da
das land auch impfstoffe aus china und
russland verwendet kritik daran ist
allerdings unerwünscht
britta hilpert drk backes ist hausarzt
in rdr tisch und er hat den kühlschrank
voll mit sinopharm dem chinesischen
impfstoff schauen sie sagt er alles auf
chinesisch r traut ihm nicht
überraschungs chinesische impfstoff hat
keine eu-zulassung und immer hat sie
nicht kontrolliert deshalb wolle er das
nicht spritzen hatte er öffentlich
gesagt behinderung der impfkampagne sei
das beschieden die behörden 3500 euro
strafe pandemie und meinungsfreiheit
gehen und ganz schwer zusammen
die regierung will als guter
krisenmanager gelten ungarn ist einer
der eu meister im impfen das soll die
infektionszahlen senken
doch ungarn hat auch eine der höchsten
todesraten der welt es fehlt an
medizinischem personal seit jahren
wandern viele ab in andere eu länder das
recht sich in der pandemie nur wenige
reden darüber wie der klinikdirektor in
rust wir betreuen auf der
intensivstation 17 ko wie kranke an
beatmungsgerät mit personal das sonst
nur sieben betten betreut
es sei furchtbar sagt er noch täglich
würden sie überrannt eine lüge sagen die
behörden
der direktor lehnt nun interviews ab
doch premier orban selbst beklagt dass
so viel medizinisches personal außerhalb
umgangs arbeitet wir wollen sie nicht
aus ihrem gewohnten lebensrhythmus
herausreißen sagte wenn wir nicht dazu
gezwungen sind eine drohung die zeigt
wie sehr ungern am limit ist doch die
regierung verspricht impfen und lockdown
sollen bald die wende bringen
der inhaftierte kreml-kritiker alexej
nawalny hat einen hungerstreik begonnen
er will erreichen dass ein arzt seiner
wahl zu ihm kommt teilten alleine auf
instagram mit der 44 jährige ist in
einem russischen straflager und leidet
nach eigenen angaben unter schweren
rücken schmerzen und
lähmungserscheinungen im bein
seit langem versucht die eu-kommission
polen zum einhalten rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien zu bewegen jetzt verklagt sie
das land erneut vor dem europäischen
gerichtshof
es geht um ein neues gesetz das nach
ansicht der kommission die
unabhängigkeit von richtern untergräbt
zurück nach deutschland trotz des
schattens ganzer branchen zur eindämmung
der korona pandemie ist die zahl der
arbeitslosen saisonbedingt gesunken
im märz waren zwei millionen 827.000
menschen auf jobsuche und damit 77
tausend weniger als im februar
die arbeitslosenquote liegt bei 6,2
prozent im vergleich zum vorjahresmonat
gibt es allerdings 492.000 arbeitslose
mehr
ein wichtiges urteil heute für alle die
in uniformen oder besondere
schutzkleidung arbeiten es geht darum ob
das anziehen der uniform zu hause als
arbeitszeit gilt und vergütet werden
muss nein sagen die richter vom
bundesarbeitsgericht zumindest dann
nicht wenn es an der arbeitsstelle
umkleideräume gibt christian decker hat
details
frank müller ist seit jahren im
objektschutz der berliner polizei
beschäftigt dort bewacht er unter
anderem botschaften
jeden tag muss er seinen dienst in
uniform antreten
ausgerüstet mit pistole reserve magazin
handschellen reizstoffsprühgerät
schlagstock und schutzweste weil er
ständig woanders eingesetzt wird zieht
er sich zu hause um das dauert pro tag
14 minuten
diese zeit soll als arbeitszeit bezahlt
werden genau wie der weg zur arbeit
fordert sein anwalt wenn er das anziehen
muss und nur so zum dienst erscheinen
kann ist dieses anziehen bereits
arbeitszeit weil ein normaler
arbeitnehmer muss solche dinge
logischerweise nicht anziehen
das bundesarbeitsgericht sieht das heute
anders denn frank müller habe die
möglichkeit gehabt sich bei der polizei
umzuziehen
wenn ich mich frei entscheiden kann mich
zu hause um zu ziehen auch wenn ich eine
auffällige uniform anziehen muss dann
bekomme ich das nicht vergütet genau so
ist der weg zur arbeit auch
grundsätzlich teil meiner privaten
lebensführung für alle beschäftigten in
uniform hat das urteil aus erfurt
grundsätzliche bedeutung sowohl im
öffentlichen dienst als auch im privaten
sektor
es handelt sich dann um bezahlt der
arbeitszeit wenn beschäftigte sich im
dienst also zum beispiel in einem
umkleideraum umziehen sofern es einen
gibt und auch nur der weg vom
umkleideraum zur arbeitsstätte zählt als
arbeitszeit gibt es aber keinen
umkleideraum dann zählt es zur
arbeitszeit wenn man sich zuhause
umziehen
noch mal zurück zu coruna mit einem
sonderweg versucht der landkreis
böblingen das virus in den griff zu
bekommen mit flächendeckenden
schnelltests seit anfang februar können
sich die böblinger zweimal pro woche
gratis testen lassen
zwei wochen später und nach vielen
testungen erreicht die kurve hier in
euros im vergleich zur gesamten
württemberg einen höhepunkt doch dank
der früherkennung von infektionsketten
sinkt die inzidenz danach deutlich seit
8 märz steigt sie zwar wieder doch in
den letzten tage ist ein rückgang zu
verzeichnen insgesamt bleibt die kurve
weit unter dem landesweiten schnitt
petra otto berichtet
sie testen hier wie es brezeln backen
fast 60.000 mal seit februar an
mittlerweile 43 stationen im ganzen
landkreis anmeldung online qr-code
vorzeigen abstrich in fünf minuten alles
erledigt das ergebnis komplett aufs
handy wenn der kunde seinen code in
seine handy app gescannt hat sieht er
alles digital viel personal zig-tausende
tests pieren schittenhelm sea de wird
immer größer und erfolgreicher die
hälfte aller corona fälle im landkreis
wird in solch einem testzentrum entdeckt
viele grundschüler übrigens und viele
die aus antworten seien es wieder heute
gerade heute morgen eine was ich bin
positiv das kann doch gar nicht sein
das sind eben genau die menschen die wir
hier detektieren die hoch infektiös sind
sie dann draußen rum rennen andere
anstecken und das passiert bei uns eben
nicht wenn das angebot leicht zugänglich
vor allem flächendeckend sei dann ging
die zahlen runter und wenn es keine test
muffel mehr gäbe meint der landrat auf
der seine seite heißt er mehr freiheiten
heißt aber noch sehr sehr viel
konsequenter sein und dem thema testung
qst wenn es um das täschchen geht bin
ich für eine testpflicht hier in
holzgerlingen haben es viele gar nicht
so eilig mit der freiheit trotz
schnelltest weil steigende zahlen findet
das eigentlich mit verdonnern ja ich
denke es müssen wir alle zusammen noch
mal aus alt lotte als richtig an ließ
berühmtesten ich hoffe dann wird's
wieder geöffnet alles in tübingen ist
schon vieles auch schon für getestete
doch die inzidenz von um die 30 übers
wochenende mehr als verdoppelt wenn das
so weitergeht fürchten sie den
modellversuch abbrechen zu müssen jetzt
fußball kritik an der wm in katar gibt
es schon lange aber noch nicht von
dieser seite ja dann mit toni kroos ist
erstmals ein internationaler
spitzenpolitiker aufgestanden und redet
klartext katar sei so wörtlich absolut
inakzeptabel wegen der
menschenrechtsverletzung einen wm
boykott lehnt er ab protestaktion aber
befürwortet er auch während der spiele
vor dem qualifikationsspiel gegen island
haben die nationalspieler bereits gegen
die bedingungen im wm-gastgeberland
protestiert wie gross der schon vor der
partie verletzt abgereist war wird jetzt
mit einem podcast noch deutlicher ich
finde die vergabe an katar nicht gut
das eine sieht die arbeitsbedingungen
das andere dass homosexualität dort
unter strafe steht und verfolgt wird das
in punkte die absolut inakzeptabel sind
bei den bauarbeiten sollen mehr 7000
menschen gestorben sein
dennoch rät amnesty international von
einem boykott ab die probleme sind seit
der verkündung 2010 bekannt und sollten
vor ort über visiert werden
generell bin ich der meinung dass er für
einen boykott zehn jahre zu spät dran
sind da die vielfalt später verblüfft
feststellte dass es im sommer dort heiß
ist ende die wir eben kurz vor
weihnachten 20 22 und bleibt umstritten
und vor dem anstoß des länderspiels
deutschland gegen nord mazedonien fragt
zdf heute live um 20.15 werden in katar
boykottieren zu gast fußball manager
andreas rettig sie können mitdiskutieren
in der zdf- heute- app auf youtube und
facebook
rudi völler wird nächstes jahr sein
engagement als sportchef in leverkusen
beenden
seit mehr als 20 jahren ist völler für
die werks-elf aktiv als spieler in den
90er jahren danach als trainer und in
der geschäftsführung in der zeit gewann
bayer übrigens keinen einzigen titel und
scheiterte zuletzt erst im dfb
pokalfinale an bayern münchen in der
frauenfußball champions league ist
wolfsburg im viertelfinale ausgeschieden
nach dem 1 2 im hinspiel verlor der vfl
auch das rückspiel gegen chelsea in
budapest diesmal klar mit 0 3
ja sie diesmal eine nummer zu groß für
vorjahresfinalist wolfsburg nach foul an
samantha kerr ist essex wolfsburgerin
paneele harder die für die londoner
rinnen in der 27 minute zur führung
trifft nur vier minuten später sorgte
samantha kerr mit dem 2 0 für die
vorentscheidung vier tore brauchen die
wolfsburgerinnen jetzt fürs weiterkommen
doch sie können ihre chancen nicht
nutzen
in der 81 minute sichert fremdkörper
chelsea mit dem 13 0 den einzug ins
halbfinale
gegnerinnen dort könnten die bayern sein
wir könnten morgen den einzug ins
halbfinale schaffen
dankeschön bitte aufmüpfige kinder das
weißt du auch warum in den besten
familien vor
selbst während die mama im stress will
mit ihrer truppe über eine straße im us
bundesstaat connecticut doch die
youngsters haben ihren eigenen kopf und
einige zweifeln ob es auf der anderen
seite unbedingt schöner ist da wird
verkehrserziehung zur reinen nervensache
am ende schaffen es alle heil rüber auch
dank sehr geduldiger autofahrer geduld
ist sicher auch beim lotto gefragt die
gewinnzahlen lauten 1 12 16 24 31 48 und
die superzahl 4 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 177 mit dem
frühsommer geht's morgen von norden
langsam zu ende die details hat gleich
katja hornuf christian sievers freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen
unbeschwerten abend machen sie es gut
und bis morgen
[Musik]
genau wie meine damen und herren heute
sind einige temperaturrekorde für ende
märz geburtstag mit temperaturen von 26
oder 27 grad einige rekorde hatten 50
jahre oder sogar noch etwas mehr bestand
die stammen noch aus dem jahr 1968 ganz
im norden sehen sie einige hohe
wolkenfelder und die ziehen jetzt in der
nacht weiter nach süden
da ist es also in norddeutschland zum
teil etwas bewirkt sonst aber es ist
häufig klar und die temperaturen sinken
auf 9 bis 2 grad
diese dichteren wolken ziehen morgen
weiter richtung norden und ihr richtung
ostdeutschland da kann es auch mal ein
bisschen tröpfeln vielleicht meinen
mecklenburg vorpommern oder auch in
sachsen südwestlich von sauerland
thüringer wald und oberpfälzer und
bayerischen wald dagegen bleibt es sehr
sonnig da steigen die temperaturen also
auch morgen noch mal auf 20 bis 25 grad
an der küste gibt es dagegen einen
richtigen temperatursturz da sind das
morgen nur noch so 8 ist 11 grad
an karfreitag kommt die etwas kühlere
luft auch in süddeutschland an es bleibt
aber trocken an karsamstag liegen die
höchsttemperaturen nur noch so bei 6 bis
14 grad der ostersonntag bringt uns dann
viel sonnenschein bei temperaturen
zwischen 9 und 16 grad und am
ostermontag kann es dann hier von
nordwesten sogar schnee in den
mittelgebirgen geben schönen abend noch